ciao ragazzi ben tornato e una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi abbiamo
deciso veramente di festeggiare questa
giornata con lo zucchero filato e
cercavo una ricetta così carina che
permettesse di fare lo zucchero filato
senza avere però la mano dello zucchero
filato ho visto quelli che impastano con
le mani sta specie di caramella
giapponese vecchia di anni e anni alla
fine ti ritrovi questo zucchero filato
me volevo proprio la palla la nuvola
grazie alle ricerche della nostra
redazione composta da gianmarco abbiamo
trovato un video di project nim che crea
a casa una macchina dello zucchero
filato se voi non avete i componenti e i
materiali che vi sto per presentare
sappiate che pagherete tre volte tanto
quello che paghereste offrendovi così
direttamente la macchina dello zucchero
filato
ma chi sono io per giudicare perché
ognuno di voi potrebbe avere a casa sua
terzo una smerigliatrice angolare
insomma è presente nelle case di tutti
quanti gli italiani serve per
smerigliare non so nemmeno che cosa
voglia dire sinceramente smerigliare
gira velocissima quindi permette allo
zucchero di partire in tutte le
direzioni e quindi e creare quella
specie di nuvoletta o almeno speriamo
che funzioni così detto ciò passiamo
subito con gli ingredienti per farlo
zucchero filato a casa avrete bisogno di
zucchero una smerigliatrice angolare il
tappo di un barattolo una busta di
plastica una punta a una bottiglia di
plastica è uno scatolone ma dovete
granger e secondo voi meccanica
mettiamo il grembiule ok
avevo chiesto giammarco se devo portare
il trapano da casa e lui mi ha detto c'è
l'ampia fece scontravano noi riusciamo
ad accedere alla stanza col trapano
quindi dovremo forare questo coperchio
correnti potremo installarlo acuta di un
cacciavite
interessante il tuo punto di vista
scusa ma staccano semplicemente come si
deve leggo questo sono infiniti carlo
modelli su questo va p proviamo un video
perché aveva portato da casa una un
trapano
non lo so che a casa non lo fate a casa
per favore aspettate però mi ha dato il
segno bravi ma digitale me lo chiedono
in molti
e questo ce l'abbiamo
bravo bravo tutti i book iniqua come
cazzarola glieli facciamo tenere calcio
vedere scaldato ho fatto il primo buco
funziona ma questo era già un buco e
stavo cercando di fare da sette ora
pagato mi si sfonda la mano non so cosa
sia questo no l'impiegato ok inserto
quanto il largo io ho il controllo poi
ma ti rendi conto che fai molto prima
compratelo perché aperto studi sto
facendo dei fori enormi potrei provare a
richiuderli dall'interno pratico
e non lo fate a casa tutto sto busi poi
non so nemmeno se funziona o no ok è
così finito di riciclo sono stati sono
larghi se non è una cosa positiva
vediamo che succede invece dsi prime
criticarci
restituiamo ci ammazzeranno uccidere
avere ragione ma lo scotch gianmarco
guardarlo
[Applauso]
qualcosa serve per togliere i peli dei
cani non ci credo io a casa mia ho 27
tipi di scotch larghi così più che altro
perché sennò ci parte ovunque
già i bookies allarghi in realtà
basterebbe benissimo che uno prenda uno
scatolone più grande però noi abbiamo
preso direttamente quello col quale era
arrivata la smerigliatrice se riesce
questa cosa tranche si sa non ho idea di
come possa riuscire stiamo già
sbagliando tutto prendendo forma anche
perché tu non puoi dire che non sia lui
e tu sei incastrato gianmarco nel dover
dire che era meglio così sotto sotto a
questo punto dobbiamo creare un foro che
permetta a questa smerigliatrice di
entrare dentro ho in mente una roba
balistica ragazzina questa porticina qua
a una porticina ancora più piccola
io ho smesso di seguire il progetto
ormai dio taglio qui stiamo creando un
passaggio major
ok poi si chiude ea un passaggio più
piccolo solamente per il cav operarsi
vedrete un sacco di volte rigo qua
dentro perché se no non so come farvelo
vedere
dobbiamo bloccare questo coso che poi in
sé raggirare sua vedere una lotta
[Musica]
io sono terrorizzato da questa ricetta
preferivo quando siamo al microonde se
non deve stare abano rai non regge pure
sul momento funziona funzionale rosta
utilizzare una bottiglia di plastica
serve per coprire la smerigliatrice li
facciamo un taglio verticale
e a questo punto utilizzano tecniche
dell'abbraccio francesco direi ci può
stare
allora ok qui dicono però di fare una
cosa staccare la spina e fare in modo
che sia settato swan riaccenderlo
direttamente così cioè ogni volta gli
devo mettere questo caso mentre gira più
vi piace
una rubrica esatto senti questa roba qui
giuliano che cacchio dell'acqua maggio
scrive non temere le caramelle più denso
dobbiamo solamente ora fare questo
composto anche presto con politico
subito vara durante tutto quanto viene
buono e non mi sento tranquillo quanto
dice la ragazza 16 un cucchiaio d'acqua
ringraziamo di.bi punto minecraft
puntoit a vita vita perché abbiamo
trovato delle dosi ragazzo si era
infilato sempre allo che ha lo stesso
perfetto come gli è andata male
questo è il concorso che per stare con
lui per portare mi sorbelli queste cose
ma cosa devo fare quindi bisogna
buttarlo questo secondo l'anci da
completare ho visto la linea 250 di
zucchero 200 di acqua
facciamo la facciamo esatto la metà
facciamo ad ora su 100 e 125 anni sta
sopportando più fuori e dentro 104 204 e
100 con 126 130 130 come 230 eventi
averci arriva se questi solo di sollievo
ma etico nome calma forse l'azione di
meyer andrea reazione di mariani alla
reazione di maiale quanto manca per la
l'effetto di miami
siamo arrivati alla alla
caratterizzazione di meier stava
famosissima si può riconoscere come
potete vedere no
mayer bayern che poi ora lo stiamo
facendo ma che notoriamente mercy stare
più sennò le bollette a rallentare
quando nel bu iniziare la lenta rodi che
sull dopo 120 dice mai
non vogliamo provare a versarlo così un
attimo e 545 più bello più termometro
c'è troppa acqua ancora un grande anno
sono 120 parole della chef sono un po
più lente sono meno frenetica mi
sembrano uguali e prima comincio a
sentire l'odore giusto con el'odore
giusto scusa naso da tartufo non mai
abbaiando
ma mai hard ma yard che cos'è che
sarebbe una reazione degli zuccheri al
calore per cui si scuriscono di tanto 40
gradi e motori e componibile questa è
una ricetta di successo
no l'hai detto l'hai detto senti l'odore
del successo
[Applauso]
ho fatto la mamma aspetta un sogno per
l'assistenza c'è un dio è venuto un po
più logico e giusto avere titolo
[Musica]
dentro tutto di un boccone allora
esperimento zucchero filato è riuscito
per metà questi batuffoli di lui è
diverso quindi il consiglio secondo me
quello che mentre lo fate bloccate e
prendete i batuffoli ni e non li unite
fra di loro
cento grammi d'acqua per 125 g di
zucchero lo fate bollire finché myard
non trasforma lo zucchero in un
caramello che vi dico porterà ad avere
questa consistenza sì sì sì sì sì sì
viene una specie di miele lo tirerete
fuori che ancora fa le bolle però poi
automaticamente diventerà una roba
pazzesca
ci hanno provato a fare a casa academy
sulle vostre foto denunciava ma
soprattutto fatemi capire che cos'è che
ho sbagliato e perché è uscito chiediamo
la massima settimana con un'altra
puntata
ciao un altro il mio dubbio è che i fori
possono essere molto molto molto larghi
forse facendo ai fori ancora più sottili
lo zucchero esce in maniera ancora più
filamentosa scalano italiana su come
tutto è sbagliato creati usavamo di
pubblici niente di plastica fondo bucato
e ha fatta